hi I'm Mah uh palini submania I am
uh oh no title cool uh I basically head
up software at a company called ubiquity
networks uh anybody you heard of us
ubiquity 1 two 3 4 okay ubiquity
networks is the largest Network Hardware
provider that all but four of you have
never heard of it
is we basically build Hardware that you
use to hook up any two places that you
can pull a cable in between so anything
from like Wi-Fi hotspot Hotspots for
rooms to microwave cannons that you can
use to do Gab links
between any place that you got line of
side connections between Long Haul Wi-Fi
remember those Pringles cans that
Pringle cans that you could use to do
whatever we productized that we sold a
couple million of those I mean it's
amazing so we're this big huge uh
multinational company whatever uh which
makes Pringle scans it's
great so on a serious note um I had up
software for the company and and uh
today what I'm going to do what I'm
going to start with is break the first
rule which is I'm going to tell you what
I'm not going to be talking about you're
not supposed to do that by the way in
case you didn't know this so I'm not
actually going to be going to be talking
about erlang the syntax or erlang the uh
the specifics of the language because
quite frankly you can pick that up
anywhere you can get in a book and if
you really want to know more about it
Robert vering who's one of the creators
of earing is teaching a course over the
next 3 days just down the road and heck
you know I couldn't recommend it higher
he's brilliant and it's a great
course that said what I'm going to be
going over is kind of the philosophy
behind erlang you know what's the origin
story why would you a write stuff in
llang and
B think in llang which is probably much
more important what's essentially
happened now is after years and years
and years of Earl
langing I do everything in llang and
when I say everything in llang by the
way I'm not just talking about writing
applications we architect our systems
kind of in an llang style hell we
architect are organizations in an early
style my development teams are set up as
if they're earling applications this
will make sense by the end of the talk
trust me on
this
yeah
so Earline so the thing
is the real thing is at the end of the
day
happens and you really have no control
over
this you have uh have you heard of
Nicholas talb the blacks onean yeah yeah
okay that's going to happen you got no
choice about
that what you want to try and do is
prevent yourself from shooting yourself
in the
foot before the Black Swan shows up you
know at least control the things that
you have some control over and we're
kind of we're going to get into some of
that but let me start with a little
story kind of give give you a bit of
context around all of this
so aha it didn't take very long for my
thing to stop working there we go so
this is a story this begins about 3
years ago I was about to head out on
vacation and uh that by the way is not
the Taj Mahal that is something called
bi makbara which is somewhere in the
middle of India it is the guy's grandson
he built this on the cheap it's mostly
like concrete and bad Stone and stuff
still pretty spectacular but it's not
the Taj Mahal we were going there to see
this place and these ancient things in
India whatever I was in New York about
um just across the river on that side
so this where we're going to end up to
be really precise this is the day before
we ended up out there so here's what
happens we I got a flight on British
Airways at 8:00 p.m. that night London
Bangalore life is going to be great 2
weeks off the grid
party um little tiny failure in one of
our servers it's a bit of context here I
used to run a phone company I started a
phone company in
1999 it built up to this big huge honken
thing we were scattered across and data
centers and hosting providers and
whatever and just great huge thing it
was great by the way if you ever want to
run a phone company don't but you know
for those of us who did it was fun you
know good money blah blah blah one
server one little honey server in Iraq
somewhere crashed so what do you
do we had architected our systems
beautifully server one of the processes
crashes just you know just just just
click the button hit the start button
boom you know and is a server
everything's good it comes back up
everything's okay except as it turned
out when I say boom I mean everything
went down when I say everything went
down I mean we went down worldwide it
wasn't just a oh the east coast is down
or oh us is down I mean we were down
completely so we kind of did a little
bit of postmortem about the thing try to
figure out exactly what happened why did
you know one little tiny server being
rebooted cause this kind of cascade
effect that went everywhere and and it
turned out there were a bunch of little
tiny things that all kind of
interconnected and reacted together so
somebody makes a phone
call can't get through because it
systems down or that one particular note
that they call would have been on us
down so what do you do when you don't
get through you call again and you call
again and you call again till you get
through I mean that's what everybody
does so effectively what is happening is
because that one node was down the whole
volume spiked on that note by like a
factor of three or four makes
sense we had this little fail safe in
our system when
um a node goes down we just route the
calls to
voicemail you know what fine it's smart
it's a smart thing to do say do that
didn't think little tiny detail
voicemails get transcribed voicemail
transcription sucks up
CPU so all of a sudden CPU starts
spiking on a couple of other nodes and
those nodes start crapping
out eventually so you know you got not
just the main node the backup nodes are
going down because the CPU is spiking
eventually the caches start timing out
and they're caches everywhere so we
start loading stuff from dis you can see
where that
goes
so you know that was just a complete
disaster happening so at this point east
coast goes down boom once the East Coast
went down people are just flooding the
Facebooks and the twitters and the what
have you saying you guys suck you guys
suck do whatever sending us emails so
basically our HTTP and our web servers
are being hit off the charts script
kitties are at work you get the
point everything goes
down and I mean it really was like a
complete full-on hardcore
down so the obvious question is the
really obvious question that comes to
mind
here didn't you guys test stuff right I
mean that's what you do you should have
known you should have tested didn't you
do any live testing didn't you bounce
servers didn't you whatever and the
thing is yes we did we absolutely
did Iowa the Thousand-Year flood Katrina
the 100y year storm it's like when you
stop oh hey you know what we're set up
if an asteroid hits equinex East we're
still good we're in equinex
West no fine asteroid hits equinex East
and and another asteroid hits equinex
West what do you do then well no then we
go to our backup center in
Fukushima yeah fine you know
so the bottom line behind all of this is
black swans and this is just the point
I'm trying to get at behind this this is
the background here is going to
happen the Black Swan is going to kill
you the thing that hit us was that weird
bizarre Thousand-Year flood that you
really can't expect it is going to
happen and quite frankly there's an
entire other talk about how do you
survive and how do you react
appropriately to black swans and what do
you do about black swans and how do you
minimize black swans this isn't that
talk the whole point behind this is
you're hosed
anyhow don't make it
worse so because the black SW is going
yes oh okay Black Swan basically is a a
once in a lifetime event that you
absolutely cannot plan against but it's
just going to show up the financial
crisis of 2008 was a black swarm uh
Nicholas
talib's premise Nicholas talib's premise
um effectively
is without going into too much detail
effectively is the more risk you take
out of a system the more you shove the
risk into the tail of whatever you're
doing and when that tail hits you it's
it's going to be a
d which is an entire other discussion
about the financial crisis and so on and
so forth but that's the kind of thing
you're talking about here so what we had
effectively done was build exactly that
kind of a situation system where we had
set ourselves up so that when the Black
Swan hit it was a complete doozy the
good news was we're back up in about 8
hours the bad news is it took us 8 hours
to come up the really entertaining news
about that to digress you know we
eventually ended up coming back
up oh we did a whole bunch of other
stuff along those lines but the final
the key touch there was uh Greg one of
the CIS admins was sitting at the Colo
and he was doing active Q management by
pulling our uplinks in and out of the
socket going 2 seconds 2 seconds 2
seconds and that was he was throttling
traffic that way it worked it was
amazing but you know it
yeah in this scenario what was the Black
Swan was it the single server going down
or something else I'm not sure what you
okay in this particular situation the
deal was we had this very weird
congruence of Cs coming from a bunch of
different places and High um it was the
peak it is it was between 10:00 a.m. and
noon uh East Coast time which is when
most of the people in the world are
online at the same time
and at about the same time the people in
Tokyo were just going off and the
voicemails were starting to spike to
them it I've got like this huge document
which I had to do for our board which
was um you know this is why we're down
for 8 hours and this is why we lost $1
million and I'm sorry but uh you can't
fire
me you know exactly yes so yeah uh it
was it was one of these things where if
you happen to hit everything at just
right and we roll like a resent
frequency it actually was one of those
things yes Cascade failures so so so so
so how do you prevent yourself from
shooting yourself in the
foot it's all about fall tolerance it
begins with fall tolerance it ends with
fall tolerance you have to build your
system to be fa
tolerant it it's a little known thing
but there is actually a formal
definition of fall tolerance it just
isn't you know oh hey hey yeah fall
tolerance
make sure that you're reliable it's
there are six very specific things that
anything needs to possess for it to be
fall tolerant if you break it down it
comes out to the following thing number
one concurrency you need to be able to
do more than one thing at the same time
why so if you can only do one thing at a
time and that one thing hangs you're
dead so you got to be you got to have at
least one other thing that can say yo
this thing's hung kill
it concurrency
fault detection you got to know
something's busted if you don't know
it's busted you can't fix it you got to
know what's
busted when it gets busted you got to
contain the
effects oh
wow that person over there is coughing
it's either Ebola or something stuck in
their
throat you identified a
fault you're or you you detected a fault
they're coughing you're trying to
identify what it is Ebola or something
stuck in their throat if it's something
stuck in their throat you don't care if
it's Ebola you want
to Bubble
whatever exactly quantin error
encapsulation you got to fix be able to
fix the
problem code upgrades when we're talking
about fixing the problem we're not
necessarily talking about oh shut
everything down and and bring everything
back up again we're talking about
don't in place in C2 fixing of the
problem remember you're running things
multiple things at the same time you
want the things to be able to to
continue working to the extent that they
can while you're fixing it and the last
one which is a bit of a tricky one which
again deserves its own talk I won't get
into it too much stable storage and the
point behind this is you need to be able
to return to a last known good State you
need to be able to say oh hey yeah um
over here everything was good I can now
go back and reassess the situation and
figure out what I want to be able to do
that that kind of an
environment so these are the big six
concurrency fault detection fault
identification error encapsulation code
upgrades and stable storage formally
defined if your system if your language
if your processes have these six things
and you're doing them properly you can
have a you will have a fall tolerance
system you can pretend you have a fall
tolerance system if you have some of
these but there is a failure mode
somewhere out there that's going to bite
you in the
butt which takes us to
erline which is kind of the point behind
this you know the secret the this is
where the rubber hits a road years and
years and years ago Joe Armstrong
captured lightning in a bottle there
it's an entire other story but he
basically figured out that these
six things formally can be implemented
in a language in an interconnecting
interlocked way so that you would have a
language that can be a language and an
environment that can be used to build
fault tolerant
systems and let's kind of take these one
at a time why these are relevant in a
language so start with
concurrency you got to be able to do
things at the same time yes absolutely
it's true you can do things concurrent
you can do things concurrently in like
an Infinity of languages hell you can do
it in assembler I mean you can write it
in anything the difference is formally
within
erlang it's kind of baked into the genes
of erlang for lack of a better word to
give you a bit of context kind of take a
look at the typical way you write
concurrent code in most languages what
you do is there's a bunch of concurrency
horror that you deal with mutex and
semaphor and shared memory and
interprocess communication and uh pick a
poison it's doable hell I mean Google um
writing concurrent applications in
Java you'll get like 8,000 hits or you
know there's everything else that does
these things I'm not saying it's it's
not doable anywhere else the difference
is um it's basically the equivalent of
being giving somebody enough rope to
hang themselves versus giving them
enough rope and making sure that they
don't hang
themselves if you're writing it in Java
it is the easiest thing in the world for
you to end up shooting yourself in the
foot it is you miss one little tiny
thing and boom you're dead in Earl Lang
you really have to fight to get to the
point where you will have shared memory
somewhere you can do it it's possible
you have to like mess around with the
process registry people do it too but
people
do when the universe comes to an end
it's because somebody's going to look at
the big red button somewhere that says
do not
push and they pushed it it's going to
happen so effectively what you end up in
erlang is you lose this part you're
basically writing the system that you
want to write without worrying about the
details of meta of mutexes and semop for
and IPC and all that stuff that said
that's a lie that's actually not the way
the system works would you actually have
this more like
this what people tend to forget is
there's stuff that you're trying to
build there's a bunch of deep problems
associated with the stuff you're trying
to build and then there's all the crap
associated with new Texas and 7 fors
deep problems um paos raft whatever
you're trying to do some kind of
distributed uh leader election algorithm
that's a deep problem it's hard I mean
raft just came out recently and it's
like the the new thing or
whatever that's not going away you still
have to solve that
problem but you don't have to worry
about this stuff and that Earline gives
you for
sure fault detection yes is this like
abstraction over seor and all that stuff
actually no Essen what ends up happening
is in
llang um at a very at a very basic level
you
have the
lowest thing that exists is a process a
process is a right now it's about a 500
byte entity which is kind of the
equivalent of an old school Allan K
object so think of it as a thing that is
it's an actor it's an actor now
effectively what it does is it contains
its data it contains its
methods the data is immutable it's
functional the data is immutable the
methods are the message methods are
invoked by messages and the only way to
get the process to do something is to
send in a
message so effectively what happens is
when you look at a running Earline
system you got like millions of
processes running around and they're all
sending messages to each other it's kind
of like a crowded room where everybody's
talking to everybody else
there yes there is complexity involved
in this because you have to think
concurrently you can't think uh I'm
going to do this then I'm going to do
this then I'm going to do this it's like
they're all running at the same time and
they're all talking to each other
but Bingo and that is the point there is
of at the botom
theot yes
exactly these are processes not like
unit processes that is precisely the
case they've got nothing to do with
threads they' got nothing to do with um
whatever it's a the term process is a
poor term uh in fact I was just
discussing this earlier this goes very
deep into the guts of the way the erlang
uh virtual machine works if you look at
the schedular for the um for the beam
which is the um the virtual machine for
Earline look at the way the schedular
works every single thing that runs every
single Atomic command that runs in llang
has
is parameterized it's got a certain
number of things called reductions just
call it call them wus it doesn't really
matter it's got a certain number of wazo
that each one must run or takes when it
runs what the Schuler does is it says
I'm going to give each process four wazo
before I move on to the next one so
effectively it is physically impossible
for a process to hog a CPU you can't it
is a new realtime system
it's unlike in go or C or Java or
anything else where an ill behaved
process can basically go you're toast
here you can't because after a certain
number of reductions the scheduler is
going to go you're out of here and go to
the next
one so fault
detection here's a simple piece of
Orland
code
effectively that's a method that gets
called and all you doing they saying um
I want to feed the cat and I give the
cat some food and the thing is depending
on what the food is that you give the
cat you get different responses only one
of the responses is a good
response the rest of the responses
pretty much suck from your
perspective now note what happens when I
give the cat
oatmeal this is by the way a
match and okay status is not going to
match eror
unhappy it's just going to barf all over
the place when this thing
happens what happens is to begin with
this is the Fault detection part it is
going to barf it's going to throw an
exception the moment that happens cool I
detected the fault that's it simple
pattern matching is this a function call
or function def is this a function call
or fun it's a function call the first
two lines are are function yeah this is
a function call this is also a function
call they're all function calls it's all
the way down to the bottom um the
difference being that oh to take this a
step it's prologue at the heart I mean
it's basically is prologue and Robert
birding when he started writing this was
a prologue guy so I said cool I'm going
to write this prologue style and then it
kind of evolved by the way
um one of the very common complaints you
get about earling is O the syntax
sucks and it does kind of suck but in my
opinion it's a good thing that it sucks
because when you look at the syntax it
really doesn't resemble things that you
see commonly and that makes you not
think of this in terms that you would
think of other things you don't have to
make this case to the list a okay then
that's a fair point I take it all back
absolutely Fair yeah true
true so fault identification the next
one so we saw the code
earlier a a huge problem in
when something barfs something explodes
what's the first thing that you end up
with you get a stack Trace stack traces
are the worst thing in the world except
in llang where they're the best things
in the world basically what you pray for
is a stack
Trace they're pretty
cool they're wonderful yes
the the usefulness in a immutable
variable world
is in a concurrent immutable variable
world is
something which is a joy to behold I
mean that's basically the best way to
describe this uh to do the really dumb
and stupid example immutable variables
everybody knows what they are but that
makes no sense in an immutable world you
already said it to one how can you
possibly set it to two and that is like
a really ridiculous statement it's like
why would you ever do something dumb
like that be smack yeah seriously yes uh
it we spend our lives unlearning
everything we learned in high school or
nowadays it's even worse everything I
learned in high school nowadays people
learn to do two completely separate
things at the same time in high school
yes this is algebra and yes this is
programming and oh yeah they do exactly
opposite things it's
like whatever so back to our cat our
unhappy cat if you fed the cat oatmeal
you'd immediately get a stack trace and
the stack Trace would say okay status
does not match error
unhappy so you would go wow error
unhappy that only happens when there's
oatmeal and you'd see in the stack race
it says okay does not match ER unhappy
it barfed out here and go back up and
say that hat barfed at line 20 when food
came in as oatmeal and then if you
follow the trace would go all the way
back up and say some other process over
here sent a message to this thing saying
feed the cat oatmeal and right at the
beginning of the day way over here
there's something that said my H was
dumb but that point is something that
you get in one single shot in your stack
trace the single biggest enemy of uh
this
stuff of being able to use stack traces
to figure out what's wrong with the
system is um when you're setting your
system up you have this remarkable
tendency no nobody sorry nobody ever is
able to set the debug level on their ER
messages correctly it's physically
impossible whatever you pick is going to
be the wrong
choice so invariably what ends up
happening is you get something that just
says oh by the way this crashed and you
don't know why it crashed so then you go
back in and then you change the debug
level and the next time it crashes it
tells you why it crashed and life is
good but
anyhow yes I'm sorry this just really
imagine somewhere in the background
using matching sorry a second using to
matching actually um no that's not
actually my question right no it's
what's that the actual question is okay
so okay and Status match correct there's
ATI mat and Status no there isn't no
no it is status is a variable but
essentially what happens is it's a left
to right match oh see see it's a very
simple left to right match goes the
other way the status would get bound and
then the master it would actually not
get bound because it
fails Bing I was wondering if you got
partial Bing yeah and the answer is no
it doesn't and the reason it doesn't is
the whole minimizing side effects kind
of situation what you want to do is have
everything happen either all or n so at
every single line that you go through uh
when you actually break this out this
stuff gets compiled into something
called core Earline which is the native
language of the
beam and um to to wind this way back
when you right so it's effectively the
way the system works is you write your
application in your line then when you
run the compiler on the thing it
generate something called an abstract
syntax stream which is just a bunch of
well you guys know what that is
so I know yeah that's why I have to keep
like unwinding my talk on this one then
it takes that abstract abstract syntax
Tre and rewrites it as something called
core erlang which is not llang it is
erlang like but it is essentially what
the beam actually
runs
that absolutely
positively must be
correct um we've got I think today there
are exactly three people that understand
how the beam actually works uh there are
four but Patrick just joined Google
about a week ago and forget that no no
seriously Patrick is yeah he's he's gone
he's lost to us at this point um but but
but actually he went there because they
want to move some of the goh scheduling
mechanisms to be
more reliably concurrent and I have no
idea how they're going to do that but
more power to them
um so continuing um error
encapsulation this one's a we bit
trickier but this is uh it's kind of
like a core a fundamental Earline
concept U you've heard of if you've read
anything about Earline or heard about it
you've heard the whole let it crash
thing the idea behind let it crash is
when fail fast fail quickly fail rapidly
fail fast when a process does something
wrong when you
see that
okay status equals eror
unhappy typically what happens in this
kind of environment is you actually just
kill the process you write your system
so that the process itself says go feed
the cat poof process
dead when you write your system from the
ground up to be like this it actually
helps it helps at a bunch of different
levels probably one of the biggest ones
which you tend to think about is garbage
collection when a process crashes you
have instant immediate garbage
collection of every damn thing the
process was
using by writing your system so that
it's nothing but a bajillion processes
Each of which spins up does a little bit
of something and then vanishes or
crashes you're getting constant
permanent garbage collection you don't
need to worry about real garbage
collection you don't need to worry about
stop the world stuff you don't need to
worry about memory allocation and all
all that good
jazz by the way everything I said Is A
Lie once you get to the point where
you're doing really deep stuff you will
end up worrying about garbage collection
and stuff but that's a good problem to
have at that point I mean it's you're
way deep into the whole thing which kind
of leads into the beam that I was just
mentioning earlier the beam is the core
virtual machine that llang runs on it is
insanely stable it is Rock Solid it is
solid to the point that the heat dep of
the universe will come before or
something bad happens by the way I'm
actually being somewhat serious about
this uh core Earline that I mentioned is
a very small set of
commands a virtually all of it and I
believe there are exactly three maybe
four places now but virtually all of it
is Lock Free I to your point when it
gets down there there there are three
maybe four places inside where there are
still a couple of locking algorithms
everybody knows where they
are as you can imagine it is some
frightfully complicated work necessary
to get that removed from the system but
that is going to happen one of these
days it is provably reliable well almost
provably reliable
because not quite going to that extent
but part of the context behind this of
course is that
um if you look around you'll see all
sorts of fun things about well you know
our environment is good because of this
use the jvm because of that uh use how
can okay a stupid point how come you
don't run on the jvm well yeah there's
something called urang that runs on the
jvm but do you want to run on the
jvm I mean I probably don't need to go
into detail on that
point code upgrade now does this mean
that there really is no process level
garbage collector there actually is it's
a two-stage gar garbage collector effect
effectively what happens is um okay
so without going too far into this thing
when you look at the garbage collection
mechanism the way it works is if objects
are referenced more than once they end
up getting pushed into a long-term uh
storage yeah otherwise poof so it's a
standard two-stage garbage collection
mechanism it's very
simple but it is very simp
simple when I say very simple I
explicitly mean as it has mean in the
sense of it has very few belts and
whistles but there's a point behind this
you make it simple and understandable so
that when you get to the point where you
have to deal with the garbage collection
you can go that's it there's not much El
going on there there are two strategies
one is to make something so simple it's
obviously correct the other is to make
it so
complicated right yeah hello jvm but yes
that kind of a thing that is not that
you cannot show it is wrong
oh that is Harsh a good
one yeah we we frequently run into
garbage
collection the second last major garbage
collection bug was one that I found and
it actually it turned out to be a
feature not a bug it's
uh basically it's one of these things
where to make the to kind of explain
this if you have a process
that gets a message and sends a message
on and there is a reference to a binary
that comes in on the message here and
goes out out there just the fact that
this process in the middle saw the
message and passed it on is sufficient
to keep that reference lying around till
this process
dies it's reference counted it's simple
it's obvious it's like well you want it
to be reference counted because maybe
I'm doing something with a binder you
never know but these are the type of
things that other when you when you when
you send a package you don't free it
exactly that sounds like a mistake
except it's not because the way tends to
work is most of the time your process
doesn't last long enough for it to give
to give a damn about these things most
of the contents of the messages tend to
be things that are small enough that
they can just be chucked this uh I
didn't get into too much I won't get
into too much detail about this because
it's one of these and the binary needs
to be of this particular type and you
need to have to done have done these
things to the binary and so on and so
forth and eventually when you realize
you're getting these out of memory
errors you track it down and then
strange nef Robert wording was the one
who
incidentally clued me in and then I read
the source code and I found out what was
going on
but which also is a good point in that
the source code is for the for
everything including the beam is
readable and you can figure out what's
going on which is
great so code
upgrade code upgrade is actually a
ludicrously trivial thing in irland yes
the um orline cor
corline it's kind of your standard uh
thingy um isn't there a major part of C
C++ C and C and C++ they're replacing
chunks of it reasonable chunks chug fit
for performance basically so effectively
any place where you want just
like bare metal performance you write it
in C or C++ appropriately I forget what
variant to C++ but it's some variant
but
so effectively a bunch of code here the
only real really relevant Point here is
U ignore this for just a
moment the way Earline works is
anything that is referencing a piece
of referencing a piece of code when it's
running will continue to ref use that
piece of code
till it either it either dies or goes
out of
scope the mo if you want to upgrade the
second piece of code that you run this
this particular routine on the piece of
code that's out here here the moment
this thing goes out of scope the next
time it comes back in it's going to find
a new piece of
code so effectively what that means is
when you up when you change the
functional when you change the
functioning of
anything everything continues to work
exactly the way it was
working
till they're done with whatever they're
doing the next time they want to use it
they get the new
functionality it's it's very predictable
it's not monkey patching you're not uh
doing you know entertaining things
trying to figure out what's going on
it's a very specific very clearcut very
well- defined way of accessing current
and future
functionality this spe particular piece
of code effectively what this is saying
is your old code had some State
associated with
it what you're just telling that program
is do something do some bunch of stuff
with the old State and return whatever
you want the new state to
be context supposing you got a routine
that takes three
parameters you won't replace it with
something that takes
four classic
example in pretty much every other
environment if you just load the thing
do a hot code load of some
kind seriously entertaining effects as
messages come in or method calls come in
with four parameters instead of three
and it's like what are you trying to do
or you write something on the stack that
you didn't expect or things here what
you're basically doing is your old thing
had three parameters the new thing's got
four parameters anything that's coming
in with three parameters and is still in
scope it's just going to keep working
perfectly when you switch to the version
that's got four if you wanted to
maintain some state in there as in yeah
you know what just make sure that the
value of fu is 13 when you go
across it'll do that there's one
additional step that you can also do you
can also pass in version number what
that essentially means is only do this
if you're currently running on version
13 if you're already upgraded don't do
anything so effectively this is this is
by the way just one of the mechanisms
that's available for code upgrades but
the point that I'm trying to get out
here is there's a very form formal clear
clean cut mechanism by which you can
patch running systems without killing
anything with granularity of this is the
process at the process level I if you
replace your caller for instance right
presing nothing happens to your own
stack that is correct okay absolutely
but it so when does the new caller
become affected when he gets control
again when does it happen call control
or what if I if F calls Bar B bar right
when is the new bar come into effect is
that when the very next time it is
accessed by food okay
yeah exactly
yes as you want butun not it's never
going to get
T that if the if the virtual machine has
inlined it it has to be quite clever
about the optimizing Bingo and the way
it does that is by being very clever
um exactly yeah the essentially what
ends up happening with a lot of these
things is you end up writing um so I'm
talking about llang there's is an entire
other level that's called OTP which is
essentially a bunch of abstractions that
are put on top of Earline that allow you
to do more complex things there's gen
server which is a mechanism by which you
can write client server
applications horrible terminology uh you
can when I say client server what I'm
referring to is you got a thing that is
a server that is serving some
functionality and you got a thing that's
a client that can access the
functionality on the server they're
basically two processes that are talking
to each other you got jfsm which is
financial a machines that you can
Implement you have gen event which is
event handling mechanisms you can
Implement gen TCP gen UDP TCP handlers
UDP handlers um you get the point UTP
handlers for bitor Stuff um
there a couple more that I can't think
of right now but yes there's a bunch of
these these mechanism mechanisms are
actually used to
upgrade higher level entities so
typically what happens is
um you package up your processes into
servers these higher level abstractions
that I mentioned you package up these
higher level abstractions into what we
call releases a releas is basically
think of it as a tarball or a
um a tball you just dump into the server
and say okay this what you want to run
what this does is it allows you to
migrate from between release
versions across all the different little
tiny pieces in the release version so
your new your release
2.1.3 you want to move it to 2.1.4 and
you're updating the functionality of
about 85 different things you can
orchestrate all of that through this so
you can say upgrade these three first
and then upgrade this then do something
else here and then do something else
here and it'll Cascade the upgrades all
through the system
so predictability always a good
thingle function thate it is any Earline
it could be it could either be just
parameters it could be functions it
could be uh and yes supports high order
functions you can have functions that
reference functions that reference you
know all the way through down the food
chain typically what you end up with in
here is exactly that you pass as a
Handler you pass handlers to uh we call
an nfas modules functions attributes so
you basically say in this module these
functions these attributes go do
something with it and that takes care of
it which is kind of your
classic quot thing you've seen the video
for this one right it's a big huge thing
it's like they change the tires in real
time but that's exactly what it's
like yes but the car is actually moving
while they're doing it yes which is
unreal it's kind of
freaky
yes upd function go from to
corre do you want to track those I mean
do that to be a problem in terms of I go
from release A to B in between I've
done right
so bit of a trick question this actually
goes back to the encapsulation concept
that I brought up earlier when I said
error encapsulation what you actually
end up doing is since in erline
everything's a process everything's
disconnected you tend to write systems
so that their functionality is very
tightly encapsulated with strong apis
message boundaries between them so yes
you could seriously screw yourself up if
you wanted
to by randomly make sending things out
and not knowing what's going on where
but the Habit tends to be released
reling often releasing
frequently releasing twice a day three
times a day whatever so the number of
things that tend to go out in a release
tend to be very small so no you would
not actually send out 150 different
changes of the three to four parameters
style what you usually would do is 150
different changes which are all bug
fixes and with continuous integration
and uh common tests and unit test and
quick check and uh things like that
quick check by the way anybody know what
quick check is two uh okay U function
Pro um property based
testing
anybody two okay uh basically the way it
works is in functional programming
languages one of the things that you can
do is you can basically
say A you can Define
the types of the parameters that get
passed into the functions and the types
of the parameters that need to come out
the other side in fact you do Define
them as part of your application so for
example here I would
say where did this
go I would say this one the type of the
parameter that comes here is an atom and
the output is a tuple which is the first
word is the first letter is first word
is okay and the second word is another
atom which is one of these four
things that just actually only this one
anything else is a failure it's going to
throw an exception so the own so the
input is any old atom the output must be
okay cing anything else is a failure so
effectively what you can do is if I see
that as a spec a specification I can
then have an automated
system uh quick check in hasal it's also
called quick check in Earline what you
what I can do is I can build an
automated system system that just says
okay I'm just going to throw a whole
bunch of random things of type atom in
on this end and see what I get out the
other end if I ever get something out
that's not purring or an exception you
mahes have a
problem yes is dialer comparable to
dialer is what you need to use to do
type
checking if the program diales then you
can run proper or quick check against it
to be able to do that so it's it's only
part of the process to do Qui
right yeah the thing islang does not
have a is not strongly typed ear line
can't be strongly typed but uh because
of that the work around is dialer what
that allows you to do is to build a
typing system that kind of works on top
of it does that mean it's not statically
typed it's not statically typed it's
dally
T so uher is rather than only accepting
programs which are provably correct it
rejects only programs that are provably
incorrect B very fundamental difference
cus seones who is the prime mover of
dialyzer is famous for saying dialyzer
is never
wrong and which as as you can well
imagine has been corrected to now say
costus is never wrong
but and if you say that to him he'll go
that is
correct it's good guy dialer
sov yes they actually ran dialer on
dialyzer and it worked I mean it was
great
um couple intangibles relevant things
one and this
is
um compared to what um Java C C++
standard stuff say
again yes well actually technically
accurate I was mentioning earlier of
been I've started uh dabbling with APL
in which
any application that's more than like 32
glyphs is a huge application you're like
okay uh not fair but um there a story
behind
this we the phone system that I
described the whole thing was written in
Java we rewrote the entire phone system
ground up in erline first pass codebase
went down by
4X second rewrite once we Rew wrote it
properly as compared to we're learning
our Lang and we're writing this stuff uh
about 3 years later we rewrote it again
it was 9.3 X 10x is an exaggeration so
9.3 X smaller than the original version
yes because uh I have a pretty basic
rule that says the third time you touch
anything you have to re refactor it and
we had refactored enough things that it
got to the point that said refactor the
whole damn thing it's I was actually
mean to ask the story of the big
meltdown where everything failed was
that one it was in ja it was in ja yes
uh it would have happened in Earline too
it was not a that's what I wasn't sure
whether there was no no correlation
there it was a it would have happened
would not have happened the same way but
it would have happened
the thing about this though is the
feedback was part of inside human being
there wasn't fixing that you just
can't at any
byting
right the thing theone gives a fatal
shock when go
through okay die actually you know it's
pretty funny it's actually pretty funny
because among the things that we did to
fix that one was we turned off we turned
off voicemail
transcriptions we just turned off um any
recording any anything that we had to do
and most importantly we made all phone
calls
free seriously I mean that is the single
biggest thing we just turn off all of
our metering and our logging and our
tracking and everything we said you
can't make international phone calls
other than that just go to
it it's shocking something like 99 point
a couple of 9% of the load on the system
was just all the crap associated with
being a phone company the phone calls
are like
nothing wait wait wait I think there's
room for something that's very much like
the telephone system but you don't leer
it closely you might have a bunch of
networks and they're interconnected and
it's called sorry yeah so so so so so
here's something that's not funny yeah
uh in
1994 I was there for this whole thing
MCI uh this a long time ago in 1994 MCI
sat around Bert Bert Roberts and Tim
McDonald and I was a fly on the wall two
of the presidents at MC were sitting on
the table and they're throwing stuff
against the wall like what can we do to
gain market share against the AT&T and
Sprints and blah blah blah and what they
came up with was you know what $20 all
you kitty
that's it we won't even give them a bill
you just pay us 20 bucks a month and you
got your phone that's it and they went
through and it turned out back then the
regul regulatory environment was
amendable to doing this you didn't have
to give people bills and when I say no
bills I mean no bills it's like 20 bucks
your phone number works that is it they
went through the entire process and when
push came to
shove they didn't do
it but what they B Bally figured out
what um one of the main reasons they
didn't do it was it turned out they'd
have to like eliminate about 80% of the
company because this proves the power of
competition to make things more
efficient I know you think you know
think how different the world would be
though today if they had done that I
mean this is well that is the world
we're in now pretty much no 1994 20
years later 20 years yeah that's about
right it takes about 20 years to get
things out of the
L and it's
sad so um brief context about um Cod to
die or
retire the US peoples basically we're
the ones responsible all of us
basically so just to Wing through some
of these things the point behind
reducing code really the point behind
reducing code is less code you have to
write the faster you can write the stuff
unless it's APL in which case it's
separate story um for those of you that
don't know APL you write in glyphs and
you it really is the truism it's a
10,000 hour rule you have no idea what
you're doing for the first 10,000
hours
um smaller code is easier to reason
about absolutely true less stuff there
is they're easier to figure out and this
is the worst part of the thing few
bugs so it turns out there's a study a
big huge longitudinal study across
everything that they did where it
basically turned out that the number of
bugs quotes around bugs don't even ask
me what it means the number of bugs per
100 lines of cod code is approximately
1.4 it turns out doesn't matter what the
language is doesn't matter what you're
doing they're bugs in it less code you
have less bugs you have simple I mean
it's like a very basic thing it doesn't
even
matter and my favorite speed refactoring
each time you rewrite it you have to
rewrite less of it and that's a good
thing
um things that you don't realize are
useful till you realize they're useful
erlang processes are location and
variant a process on my node is exactly
the same as a process on some other
nodes on a totally different node you
don't care about where things are
running it just runs as a mesh across
all the nodes that you care about which
is concurrent systems right passing
messages you don't care about where the
source and destination are the thing
about this though is it makes debugging
running systems awesomely
trivial if there is something weird
going on on one of the nodes you just
connect to the node you connect your
repple to the node you're there you're
on the thing you're doing live debugging
you're just taking a look at stuff
attach a tracer there is such a thing to
a particular module to a message from
module and can you can see where a
particular parameter in a message from a
function in a module where it passed
through this was the binary thing that
you're you're mentioning earlier you
could see where it went in its life
cycle before it got garbage collected
and by the way I don't mean in some deep
dark stack placeas you get nice pretty
little print outs that show you what's
going on it's um most of the time you
get you figure out what's going on like
that steep learning curve incredibly
useful to
use the reductions that I
mentioned
predictability ear is a near realtime
system you know what is going to happen
you will not have situations in which
something runs for a while and it sudden
hangs okay that's a lie you can make it
do
that not easily and not early on
eventually you'll get to the point where
it will happen
and you'd be dealing with
stuff performance it's actually
ludicrously fast as long as you're not
doing things like ffts or
something it's crazy fast crazy crazy
fast
um to just kind
of performance is always the is always
right and you know what write an r or
write in C or write in something else
going to do stuff like that everybody
has to all the fling Point numbers have
to be allocated on it just
ch and or Lang interpreted at the end of
the day it's an interpreted language
interpreted environment you cannot get
around that there's nothing you can do
about
that um make that fast you have a very
nice go away
but say again why is there do um part of
it is
because very hard very very hard because
of the core Earline and the beam uh
thing that's going on you know sorry
well mostly you compile code and you end
up with a be file so yeah but that's not
reallying that's B compiling it's B
compiling okay that's a
point yeah you should be able you should
be able to write a J um if there only
four people who understand then there
probably only 0.4 people who understand
how to write a jit for it so what there
is a jit it's called H hip high
performance Earl and the problem with
hype is it works incredibly well except
when it doesn't yeah probit yeah and
that's Nobody Knows Why Bingo and it's
just
hard um I've got about three minutes
which I'm going to blast through a
couple of things on this one just to
bring home the philosophy Point here the
Buddha nature the Buddha nature of
erlang remember I mentioned it's not
just the language it's the way you build
systems the way you build environment so
on and so forth if you look at fall
tolerance
systems one one of the things
is you you would hope people learn from
The Mistakes by the way the point isn't
that that's a mistake the point
is we were responsible for the Obama
campaigns
um
voter if there were problems at any
voting Center there were these phone
banks that you're supposed to be able to
call and say hey are they're not
accepting me there's the lines are too
long stuff like that we were responsible
for this back in 2008 we had this
monster capacity that we had set up
barely trickling over it was perfectly
fine and we had set up our redundancy
Seven Ways to Sunday and we started
getting calls from the campaign saying
everybody's getting busy signals what's
going on why you guys down and we're
like we're not down we're fine turned
out all the calls from Ohio were being
routed through like one central office
office somewhere in akan or something
like
that no they just ah good question I
don't
know yes it's Ohio very good question I
don't have an
answer but the funny thing is you go
through all of this fast forward 12
years uh you know the project Orca thing
that the Romney campaign set up big
monster huge thing set up in in the
Boston
Garden two problems they didn't check
the Capac data capacity out of the
garden they didn't turned out they
didn't have enough capacity they found
this out on the day of the thing this is
exactly the same as the aan Ohio thing
they just wasn't enough capacity maybe
it was somebody doing it again but I
mean the point was there wasn't enough
capacity the second thing was they also
had caset
failures they had no
redundancy they there was no they didn't
even know that there was a problem fa
detection they when they found out that
stuff wasn't working they didn't know
why it wasn't working no fault
identification they couldn't encapsulate
the problem it was just like there's a
problem somewhere we don't know what's
going on it was
Windows right they couldn't uh fix it
and it is the most amazing thing I mean
this is I'm looking at the list of
problems they postmortem I'm reading the
thing it's like I've seen seen this
before this happened four years ago it's
the same document just different
colors and the thing about all of this
is when you build your
systems using your when you build your
systems not your applications doing
this you can get this through loose
coupling you can
get where did that go right
sorry just by making sure that the
individual comp components are Loosely
coupled you can effectively do the
equivalent of processes you can set your
systems up so that a problem in one
component does not take down a different
component you can set
up back in sorry uh where' this go
right another Point here uh
um you build your system so that they're
wonderfully done they're absolutely
perfect they do everything absolutely
corrected absolutely correct odds it's
never going to go in production it just
won't something like about 90% of all
software applications never see the
light of day oh by the way it's not
because you did something wrong it's you
know what something else was important
this thing got shelv uh company went out
of business that happens too uh some
other project became more important
important the point is don't bother
optimizing don't bother trying to make
it absolutely correct just get it
working figure out the rest
later if you're not Loosely coupled if
you're not encapsulated if you cannot
identify problems right up front if you
can't fix them when they happen just
getting it working is not going to be
sufficient because everything is going
to be so tight tightly coupled with
everything else that it's just not going
to work the point that I'm trying to get
at here is is these six principles that
I mentioned earlier where did it
go these aren't just about Earl they're
about how you build your systems they
how you take it a step further um think
of the company you work at right
now how many people do you know of who
have hitot who are um hit by a bus
safe none of
them not one that's bad they are
completely nonr in human beings that's
terrible yeah it's terrible we can't
afford anymore and that is just say we
are a multi-billion dollar company with
a 500 year history the way you get to be
a company with a 500 year history is be
really really
cheap and I totally hear you yeah that's
not me but the point is that happens s
and Bob does get hit by a bus and Jane
does get run over by a truck and the
next thing you know you have a
problem um by the way it's not just
about being hit by a bus uh it's much
much worse um what's your CFO doing in
Brazil it wasn't supposed to go
there could happen walking the
Appalachian Trail yeah walking the
Appalachian
Trail I'll actually make it much much
much simpler than this from a your how
fall tolerant is your company
perspective your system whatever it is
Meetup
um I should know this whatever you're
doing spectacular wonderful fall
tolerant dead reliable
stuff um have you ever walked into the
finance
department of your company have you seen
what they
use Excel
seriously the one thing that has almost
taken the world down it almost takes the
world down once every six months
nowadays I mean rinard and rogov because
of a stupid 42 lines instead of 43 lines
addition mistake on on an XL Spreadsheet
took down
Europe Europe is going through hell
right now because they couldn't drag the
blue line all the way to column to row
43 they stopped at row
this is what the finance dep department
is running on this is what your company
depends on it doesn't matter how perfect
your application is yeah but there are
other redes in the system there very few
companies which if they fail take down
the whole
time oh actually that's is a really
depressing
statement as in there are some companies
which if they fail to take down the
whole planet but yes point taken but the
point being the point that I'm trying to
get at here
is we look at the things that we control
it's the software and we go yeah we've
got everything under control and we
ignore everything
else and those are just as
important andess
yes
so to close this
out my company thinks that we
do we kind of implement this kind this
philosophy at a bunch of different
levels every our application when
we our huge Cloud infrastructure is
broken into individual components each
there is no component that is so large
that it cannot be comprehended by one
person it is then assigned to two
people is it the most efficient way of
doing things hell
no it's good
enough and it works and one person gets
hit by a bus I don't care
functionality is encapsulated well okay
I do care but you know I I don't want
them to be hit by a bus yes we have an
in capacity for suffering other people's
nams right
but right right but you do that and you
take the law efficiency loss in the
thing you go you make sure that your
system is encapsulated problems in one
area don't affect problems in other area
when there is a problem you know that
you can find it you know that you can I
figure out what it is you know that you
can fix it you know that you
can always Retreat to a stable
place you can build everything that way
that's Earline that's how you do Earline
applications it's how you build Earline
systems it's how you do H it's how you
build your organization your
language and I've talked 10 minutes too
long I'm sorry but got side
TR